Vincent plays three-on-two for the
Lakers James instead of the bling gets
grabbed puts it in and flexes how about
LeBron James clearly to grab iMovie but
the role man strength the ability to
spin and finish the opposite hand what a
move oh good
McKee with the board two seconds to go
James a buzzer beater
[Applause]
what is it
and nails it LeBron James closes out the
first half with a 40-footer
[Music]
the down by three that could tie the
game with seven with six and years were
blown LeBron for the time of the evening
LeBron with the crop winding down long
three-pointer calmly knocks nice are
they the coachee guards Leonard Leonard
backing in clock down to two top shot
and he makes it miss Laker team they've
been losing close games as LeBron goes
one-on-one got a bucket mean he's had
three passes and I've ever really been
special he's double time by Lonzo and
the pun says I thought if you're moving
I see you I'll get it - Durga pocket
gives it back over to Kyle a bucket the
line clock down
Leonard escapes trouble steps into it
and connects it's calm and cool move
right here good movement watch Leonard
he's gonna lift the D and despite that
Davis still almost gets there going in
an oxidant wolf inside of your labor it
looks different from last year sends it
back on Stauskas now LeBron on the other
he's got 27 and taking over Staples
Center
big time block by LeBron on a defensive
end offense a little spin whoa I love LA
we authority to say enough about to
change the direction off the dribble
scam shows you that first one Isaacson
always says where did he go we went to
the rim and he finished that the rim
didn't the next trip down little spin
contact use the left and flex yep we
know you're strong cuz on James pull up
for a three here it comes
and there it goes splash Northwestern
Wildcats Ohio State
down say goodnight
Lakers are on their way to a win over
the Mavericks he's just saying I'm gonna
set a script who said nah just data let
me shoot this one from about 39 on the
defensive end looks wha why not
substitution 13 six runs since LeBron
dented back into this ball he takes it
strong role to get the switch gotta see
this one again you Kawhi Leonard
surprised at the left hand over Allen
what a slam you kidding me boom
most of the scoring but up sometimes
when you hear the whistle just throw it
up he just threw it up it went right in
he's got a three-point opportunity here
after not getting many calls in the
first half and that's what they came to
see up on their feet when he threw that
one down that LeBron comes down and look
change direct straight down the gut and
hammers down a two-handed flush job and
[Applause]
lizards
aid here the wine lettuce plant a city
game coming
no he hasn't gotten contracts 68020
in this game Crowder has it's a call by
30 you know how strong brew and then the
left this is spectacular
contact all the way and somehow able to
stretch and get that ball and clean
without using the glass wow that's
impressive there's a little more emotion
and I saw he was fed up at the beginning
of the game maybe taking a couple of
plays he doesn't usually like that
trying to loosen up but this starts with
the defense and and with emotional games
like this if you're in the playoffs you
you have a bigger goal it's a team win
but tonight when it's having a night
he's at 19
blow it down he'll go to the line and he
says okay I'll just split a couple of
defenders and then go up and get to
finish his turner with the foul and
LeBron with the three-point opportunity
from downtown the bubble goes down to
the Urban's pass picked off cheese great
plays recognition
here Larry to kowai kowai
seven 120
so coming up and up over using a glass
getting that ball up mine
tough angle right there Maddie could
still he's among the leaders in steals
by Portland for instance
[Applause]
a statue
[Music]
yeah somewhere tape backing her crime
that's what were they used to do about
to Ian Clark for three no good long
rebound kuzmic James goes to the
contestant with the Sun missed it batted
out to Rhonda a little bit of resistance
there at the rim by the lake a
ten-to-one run by the Lakers like a
Randle being physical with James shot
puck down to four LeBron lost it now he
gains fires away
[Applause]
[Music]
I've seen that a lot that's my boy next
year look at this shot I mean you can't
play the defense any better than that
that's a great possession and that's a
great defensive possession and it just
breaks your heart on those you know
you're gonna make something happen but
also here he goes right by the guy again
there it is
whistle
catches he gets he gets the foul it gets
hit hard but he plays the glass step
against heartless played two-man game
here Lillard gets switched on to him
Pillai for the win no time now no time
now that's the ball game
[Applause]
how do you like him now clean the best
and he goes right for it and the side
line that is a tough shot because it has
to be a swish or you get a lucky bounce
like they got right there that hit the
rim let's count it 1 2 3 4 times before
falling through well you know he loves
that side to the floor he's been doing
it all night long and he's been throwing
the fade away and he fits perfectly with
this group James accelerate
[Applause]
Milwaukee hears Rondo gets it to James
LeBron takes it to the rim and finishes
with the left of these foul the legend
of LeBron continues he moves past his
idol MJ her fourth on the all-time
scoring list we see the delivery from
Rondo LeBron making history as a play in
this league 70 years as a coach for
three years the best times was on the
bus all the planes traveling together
from James to Bogdan
we've seen this movie before that's just
I mean he's going to go down as one of
the all-time great scores and it's his
second best skill because his passing is
truly magical but that's what you know
it passes Michael George they're gonna
get a second opportunities take away by
the Lakers here's John
[Applause]
Oh Showtime he gets in the open court
and does this seconds and they lead it
by a little but a quick quick thought
out the rappers have a big win down in
Miami a little while ago it just tells
you how good the Rockets the befriended
us it did seem like the heat too wide
Leonard go look at some more that moving
by the Raptors make it an extra pass and
we also have to be aware of the clock
[Applause]
clock down Kauai on George backing in 13
for Leonard and and I know Rhoda Raptors
up by ten point range when we return in
him frustrated Westbrook could you know
I'm not gonna in this case Greg he
wasn't gonna be able to block the shot
stalled by the answer there
[Applause]
at the other end buying the bran to turn
over the Angela says I've got me an easy
one
whoops where did he come from rebounding
numbers in favor of chili I'd like to
see Kobe Bryant do a detail about your
preparation for the game it's a thing of
beauty he doesn't have that much detail
as Leonard with the left hand
Claude dunk Lenin dribble penetration at
the ability to pause the basketball and
finish we're in Philadelphia sit with a
dr. Jay big Tom hands
[Applause]
- witches fighters a long one nothing
but MIT then Hawai not 39 total points
Leonard peeks at the clock five seconds
that makes his move for the 76ers 37 to
17 and another Kauai light that sixes in
this game just loves the big stage and
he's been a highlight machine in the
postseason the latest one from Leonard
Ferris defends on the perimeter
[Applause]
here if you're filling it's off the
Leonard defended by Simmons is this
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by :
[Applause]
to try
he's not doing great the disk image it's
good enough to think good the soul will
device
bi-linear beautiful pass by Gasol the
left hand that comes Middleton he has
the hottest TNG is being presented by
pixel
still by Maui and the exclamation point
here and Drake the reaction what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content